il n'est pas encore arrivé en France il
est déjà là on avance oui j'ai acheté en
Chine comme ça je voulais vous le
montrer prendre le temps parce que c'est
un smartphone qui est très attendu pour
l'année 2023 on se parle ici du Xiaomi
13 pro alors aujourd'hui on fait quoi on
va
l'ouvrir si il est intéressant on va
commencer à faire un benchmark regarder
un peu ce qui vient raconter puis au
final on verra si ce Xiaomi 13
progression chinoise est plutôt cool
alors je vous le dis il y aura une
deuxième vidéo on va vraiment se
concentrer sur la photo parce que est
arrivé le partenariat avec Leica l'année
dernière avant c'était Huawei qu'il
avait maintenant c'est Xiaomi qui l'a
donc je pense que ça va apporter
beaucoup de choses au niveau de la photo
sur ce Xiaomi 13 pro alors attention on
reste ici pour l'instant sur une version
chinoise il y aura peut-être des
modifications d'un point de vue logiciel
sur la version française donc on
regardera la version française plus tard
lorsqu'elle sera présentée pour
l'instant j'ai pas encore date je pense
qu'on en février donc on se regarde ça
tout de suite vous allez voir à mon avis
on va pas être au bout de nos surprises
alors regardez on va commencer par se
l'arracher hop on va regarder ce que ça
raconte ce truc voilà la boîte bon un
très grand classique par rapport à ce
qu'on avait l'habitude de connaître chez
Xiaomi on retrouve bien le branding en
gros Xiaomi 13 pro qui est fait avec les
cas au niveau des optiques ça c'est très
chouette sur le côté à l'arrière partout
c'est sensiblement la même chose on
vient ouvrir un petit peu la bête alors
Xiaomi tresse pro le smartphone est là
faites voir ce qu'il y a là-dedans sur
les versions chinoises alors bien
évidemment si ça va être soit écrit en
anglais soit écrit en chinois autant
vous dire que je ne parle pas chinois ça
va être un petit peu compliqué donc là
il y a rien d'écrire en anglais une
petite coque de protection avec de
couvert mon tiroir de carte SIM ok
jusque là c'est très simple et ok ça
fonctionne ensuite ici et je vais venir
retrouver alors le smartphone en
lui-même qu'on regarde dans quelques
instants à l'intérieur j'ai mon bloc de
charge 120 watts alors ça effectivement
ce qui a été annoncé avec le chargeur
chinois il est vachement lourd celui-là
c'est une vraie galette un vrai galette
que c'est plus comme ça qu'il faut le
dire alors en fait nous avons de la
jusqu'à 100% en 19 minutes mais vous
avez également de la recharge sans fil
50 watts qui vous le refaire dans 36
minutes et de la recharge inversée au
niveau du smartphone en 10 watts donc on
a le bloc de charge qui est inclus ici
avec j'ai mon câble ici OK et moi ce qui
m'intéresse maintenant c'est cette
petite bête c'est le smartphone en
lui-même fait de voir on va se mourir
alors il fait son poids le bestiau hein
avec la version céramique il va faire
229 g et la version avec la techno
nanoskin on est à 218 g vu le poids
qu'on a ici je pencherait plus sur le
229 G et le poids est réparti de façon
j'ai l'impression assez homogène entre
l'avant et l'arrière ensuite regardez ce
qu'on vient retrouver alors chez Xiaomi
on a toujours ici de l'infrarouge vous
pouvez utiliser vos smartphones comme
une télécommande vous allez avoir le
micro pour la réduction de bruit en bas
de la recharge en usb-c le haut-parleur
le micro le tiroir de carte Simca
d'ailleurs faites voir ce fameux tiroir
de carte SIM regardez vous avez double
nano SIM première nano SIM là la
deuxième qui est derrière alors ici pas
d'extension micro SD par contre vous
pouvez mettre soit deux cartes
5G soit une carte SIM 5G une carte SIM
4G donc bon en fonction de vos besoins
et de vos abonnements peut-être
voulez-vous faire ça en tout cas vous
pouvez le faire sur la version chinoise
attention ici bien évidemment toujours
hop là je referme ici sur le côté le
bouton pour venir l'allumer l'éteindre
et le bouton de volume ça c'est pareil
il y a rien de bien changé ici et de
l'autre côté absolument rien et en fait
le bloc photo qui est assez pour
imminent regardez-moi ce truc là ça fait
une belle bête alors après je trouve
quand même assez sympa mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a pas de gros changement par
rapport à ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière c'est un petit arrondi là mais
comme dans les lignes directrices et à
côté un peu carré faut carré arrondi
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a pas de grand
changement alors comme on est ici sur
une version chinoise qui n'est pas faite
pour l'Europe et bien je n'ai pas la
norme CE donc vous voyez ici je la
retrouve pas je la retrouve nulle part
donc ici il y a pas de norme CE bien
évidemment par contre ce qu'on voit si
vous vous approchez on voit bien qu'on
est effectivement 3 capteurs photos en
fait c'est un triptyque 50 mégapixels
vous avez un 50 mégapixels pour grand
angle c'est la Sony IMX 989 c'est un
capteur de 1 pouce et ça c'est chouette
pourquoi parce qu'en fait le stade
dragon 8 gène 2 qu'on a ici le nouveau
le processeur de Qualcomm et bien il
vous permet d'abord un capteur de 1
pouce avant on avait des smartphones
avec un capteur de 1 pouce on avait sur
le 12 s ultra si je dis pas de bêtises
de Xiaomi et en fait il fallait un
coprocesseur d'image ici pas besoin
votre stade dragon 8 gène 2 va tout
gérer directement ça vous permet
effectivement d'avoir ça et c'est
justement pour ça qu'on va regarder
d'ici quelques jours ce qui raconte en
termes de photos et de vidéos parce qu'à
mon avis ce capteur d'un pouce il va
être pas mal le Xiaomi 12S ultra était
super beau en photo j'avais vraiment été
bluffé j'avais adoré donc à mon avis ici
ça m'a envoyé du bois on a également un
grand angle de 50 mégapixels et du très
grand angle de 50 mégapixels ce grand
angle fait aussi de la macro à 5 cm je
pense ça va être pas mal aussi au niveau
de la photo de nuit parce que vous
pouvez regrouper 4 pixels en un seul et
même gros pixel un plus gros capteur
plus le pixel binding vous voyez quatre
oh non ça devrait être fermé plutôt pas
dégueu en plus il vous donne de l'hyper
stabilisation optique l'hyper o i s tu
ferais moins hâte de voir ce que ça
vient raconter ça et notamment en terme
de vidéo lorsqu'on le tient la main vous
savez moi j'en trouve le moins essentiel
donc lorsque je vais filmer comme ça et
bien je peux vous assurer que c'est pas
stabilisé c'est un crash test on le voit
directement on a également objectif qui
va être stabilisé c'est bien sûr optique
et surtout ce que nous intéresser si
c'est le partenariat avec Leica parce
que vous avez une vraie colorimétrie
Leica il y a un vrai travail Leica je
pense ici au niveau des optiques ça va
être quand même plutôt pas dégueu alors
maintenant on va se l'allumer je vais le
configurer alors ici smartphone
fatalement je vous le dis c'est du
chinois on peut venir l'installer en
chinois et en anglais on va le faire en
anglais parce que je ne parle absolument
pas chinois l'expérience logiciel c'est
du mi-wei 14 alors c'est pareil pour moi
ça va être une découverte ici là dessus
on va regarder les nouveautés alors il y
a souvent une grosse différence entre la
version Inde Chine et la version
européenne qu'on aura après mais il a
déjà été ouvert ce smartphone regardez
je suis déjà là donc le paramétrage a
déjà été fait je me demande ce qu'ils
ont fichu en fait est-ce qu'ils l'ont
testé j'en sais rien alors je sais plus
qui est le vendeur ou je l'ai acheté
déjà on le voyant ce qu'on l'ouvre au
départ vous avez mis un petit bout de
scotch regardez il avait ouvert là et en
fait il l'avait scotché là donc là ils
me l'ont mis en anglais comme ça partait
en Europe peut-être qu'il voulait j'en
sais rien cette année une version
anglaise on se fiche vraiment rien donc
moi je vais le connecter au wifi et je
vais faire un petit
de performance sur en toutou et puis on
revient dans quelques instants le temps
d'un clap fin de l'installation et fin
du test surtout sur un toutou et c'est
ce qui m'intéresse on arrive à un score
de 1 million 242 669 autant vous dire
qu'ici sans vote du bois et si on
regarde par rapport au classement global
ici ranking un million 200 et quelques
milles hop là le calcul ça vient nous le
placer regardez en 3e position derrière
le vivo X90 pro plus derrière le hiku 11
pro on arrive juste là alors là les
carrés pas énormes et derrière on va
voir le rock fun 6 qui arrive derrière
donc vous voyez on se retrouve dans le
top 3 en fait c'est grâce au stade
dragon 8 GN2 alors vous savez les tests
sur autotou ça teste beaucoup de choses
au niveau de la performance et là j'ai
le smartphone qui a chauffé fort
derrière là là je le sens ici il est
quand même relativement chaud même au
niveau du module photo alors après ça
vient vraiment tout tester tout pousser
pour vraiment avoir un résultat qui
marche du feu de dieu et fatalement ça
chauffe ça veut dire qu'ici on a un
smartphone qui est performant en
Technodrome on est sur la lpdr 5x on a
soit 8 soit 12 giga de ram d'ailleurs
moi j'ai combien ici dans ma boîte j'ai
une version 8 Go et 256 gigas de
stockage parce que vous avez soit 128
soit 256 soit 512 Go de stockage essaie
de l'uefs 4.0 qui va aller plus vite
forcément en lecture en écriture donc
ici on a les dernières techno donc ça
c'est vraiment cool alors après il y a
autre chose que je voulais bien voir
avec vous et j'ai compris en fait
pourquoi est-ce que le smartphone avait
été ouvert parce qu'en fait il voit
salut le Play Store ce qui m'a permis de
venir installer un petit Firefox ici
d'installer entre tout directement sur
leur site parce qu'ils sont bu sur le
Play Store et d'avoir effectivement tout
mon catalogue d'application alors bon
pour autant je reste sur une version
chinoise et je vous le dis une fois de
plus même si elle est écrite en anglais
ici donc on fera peut-être une vidéo
pour vous parler de mi-way 14 d'ailleurs
dites-moi si ça vous intéresse dans les
commentaires ce que vous voulez que je
vous fasse un petite version pour qu'on
regarde ce que vient porter meway 14 en
plus de biwaii 13 qu'on avait l'année
dernière en plus de la vidéo sur la
photo qui arrivera photo et vidéo d'ici
quelques jours regardez je vous montre
quelques petites vidéos ici sur Youtube
grâce à alors pas exactement alors
attendez en fait le truc que vous avez
il y a un petit déséquilibre au niveau
du son j'ai haut parleur en bas qui va
apporter un peu plus de rondeur un peu
plus de grave que le haut parleur
supérieur le haut-parleur supérieur
viendra surtout en renfort ici vous
voyez ça c'est pas nouveau ça en fait
mais c'est un truc que je regrette parce
qu'il y a quelques années il avait sorti
un smartphone le 11 pro peut-être et en
fait je trouvais que il y avait un vrai
beau équilibre au niveau de l'audio et
ici c'est moins ça peut-être que c'est
plus facile pour eux après bon ça
fonctionne je peux pas dire que le son
marche pas la qualité aussi de l'écran
est bonne ce qui est cool ici c'est que
vous avez un pic de luminosité à 1910
c'est-à-dire que si ça vient envoyer du
bois ça veut dire que lorsque vous avez
beaucoup de soleil que vous êtes dehors
et qu'il y a le soleil qui vient
vraiment taper dessus vous allez voir
alors là je vois bien c'est clair bon je
vais baisser un petit peu quand même
parce que ça envoie du pâté tout ça on
va retourner voir un peu du côté de
l'écran brightness level ok c'est ce
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure automatique
résolution là je suis en Full HD plus
mais je peux monter en double VQ HD plus
c'est ce que je vous disais en fait
regardez 3200 par 1400 pixels alors
fatalement ça va venir taper un peu plus
au niveau de la batterie si je le mets
mais ça va venir améliorer aussi la
qualité taux de rafraîchissement ça
c'est aussi intéressant parce qu'en fait
là ils veulent mettre par défaut et si
je veux venir personnaliser en fait j'ai
le choix à regarder entre 60 et 120
Hertz en fait ici vous avez une dalle
OLED c'est du ltpo ça nous permet
d'avoir un taux de rafraîchissement qui
va de 1r c'est ce que vous êtes en noir
sur un always on display jusqu'à 120
Hertz ça va venir moduler c'est à dire
que si vous jouez à des jeux ou que vous
allez sur Instagram et que vous scrolez
comme un dingue vous avez besoin de 120
Hertz mais si par exemple on vient
regarder une vidéo vous allez pas être
en format donc ça va venir consommer
davantage si vous êtes tout le temps 120
Hertz versus si vous êtes en mode par
défaut ce que je vais recommander ici
une fois de plus on est dans les
dernières techno ici que maîtrise Xiaomi
et ça ça marche vachement bien on a quoi
l'Aïd engine super résolution ai engine
elstment ça va venir booster en fait
donc ça peut être pas mal hop là aussi
au niveau du HDR ça peut être pas mal
elle est super résolution j'ai vraiment
un accent pourri c'est incroyable au
niveau des vidéos ok ça c'est pas mal
j'aurais des colorants qu'on a
effectivement différents modes de
colorimétrie de couleur ici vivid qui
recommandé saturé saturé ça lui a poussé
davantage original et après on peut dire
customiser ici directement le saturer
moi je vais mettre du saturé j'ai bien
quand il y a un peu plus de pêche
autoroute screen ok always on display
locks il y a pas mal de petits
paramètres on regardera peut-être ça
dans une prochaine vidéo sur meway 14
d'ailleurs dites-moi une fois plus ça
vous intéresse dans les commentaires je
regarderai ça alors une fois de plus il
se peut qu'il y a une vraie différence
entre ce qu'on a ici aujourd'hui il est
en version anglaise versus qu'on aura en
France dans quelques temps donc bon et
on prend ça avec des pincettes mais en
tout cas l'expérience pour l'instant
elle est très proche de ce que je
connaissais l'année dernière il y a pas
grosse grosse différence faut que
j'approfonce et j'ai une creuser
davantage de sujet mais comme ça en tout
cas ça fonctionne à noter qu'ici vous
avez quand même un écran de 6,73 pouces
une grande dalle taux d'échantillonnage
tactile de 260 r si vous avez un
milliard de couleurs Dolby vision hdr10
plus vous avez du Bluetooth 5.3 Dolby
Atmos I rise audio wireless donc pour me
dire connecter des écouteurs sans fil
vous pourrez avoir du iris également la
batterie c'est une batterie de 4820
milliampères heure alors Xiaomi nous
annonce plus d'une journée d'autonomie
moi je vais pas forcément vous le dire
vous faites plus sur une version
étrangère ça va être un petit peu
compliqué il faudrait vraiment attendre
la version française pour avoir un
retour complet au niveau du test on
regardera ça dans quelques temps en tout
cas je vous l'ai dit de la recharge
rapide 120 watts 50 watts sans fil et 10
watts en charge inversée à noter qu'à
l'avant vous avez un verre Corning
Aurillac victus ça c'est pas mal parce
que ça va venir un peu le protéger son
creux là au centre c'est marrant ça me
cru aussi là à voir bien évidemment on a
du wifi 6 du NFC il est certifié IP68 et
c'est un smartphone qui n'est pas encore
sorti en France qui sortira plus tard on
attend que Xiaomi Vienne l'officialiser
je vous dis je pense que ça arrivera
qu'on en février on en reparlera d'ici
quelques jours pour venir regarder toute
la partie photo vidéo avec les cas qui
va être vraiment le truc qui va moins
venir totalement m'intéresser alors là
regardez vous choisissez votre look en
fait avec Leica fresh and vibreur ou
alors note 3 listing non mais je préfère
peut-être le Conseil un peu plus saturé
quoi que là c'est pas mal aussi comme ça
Laïka vibreur authentique oh mec lakea
authentique je pense que ça on pourra
venir le changer après de toute façon je
l'ai ici au niveau de mes paramètres
Leica authentique je peux vous dire
choisir ici entre le vibrante et
l'authentique donc je voudrais faire
différents tests ici sauf que ça peut
être vraiment intéressant photos
portrait ok donc ça c'est pareil j'ai
différentes choses au niveau du port ça
va être assez cool le mode nuit mort
donc je vais avoir poussé 50 megapixels
short vidéo vlogs slow motion il y a
tout télécharger ok je vais le faire la
vidéo ici les documents le pro ok donc
c'est tout un programme on va regarder
ça plus en détail donc laissez-moi
quelques jours et puis on reparlera bien
évidemment de ce chien
d'une version chinoise mais qui va
bientôt arriver en France mais on aura
déjà fait un petit tour on aura déjà
regardé pas mal de choses et ça c'est
chouette donc à vous de me dire ce que
vous voulez qu'on regarde s'il y a des
choses que vous voulez qu'on regarde en
particulier sur ce smartphone et puis
bien évidemment on en reparle dans
quelques jours pour parler toute la
partie photo vidéo je regarde ça c'est
vraiment intéressant si ça vous
intéresse dites le moi d'ailleurs en bas
on se fera un petit tour de mi-way 14 et
puis bien évidemment on en reparlera
quand la version française arrivera
d'ici quelques semaines et ça aussi ça
va être chouette donc voilà on se
retrouve très bientôt pour continuer à
parler de Xiaomi mais également de plein
d'autres marques ça c'est chouette je
vous embrasse pour les soin de vous et à
très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]